well mark i can't believe i'm i'm
literally chatting with a living legend
right here uh i can't imagine what it
was like for you to don that hat again
and step back into undertaker's shoes
for this film what did it feel like for
you how fun was it first i had to find
all the stuff
it was uh no pun intended dead and
buried almost
uh you know it was it was a lot of fun
and
i had
never heard
uh personally i never even
heard of an interactive movie before
so it was completely new to me
which is always fun you know being
involved in something new and learning
stuff i've spent a lifetime studying the
dark hearts
and uncovered many
unnatural forces
but none
compared to the urn's powers
hello
excuse me uh undertaker it's your voice
the new day but really had a really good
time it was a hectic workload uh to get
it done in the in the time period that
we had to get it done
and
really not knowing
um
you know how the product was gonna was
gonna come out and how it was gonna
resonate with people um but uh we had a
lot of fun doing it and uh
i don't know that stuff felt pretty good
obviously like i said you're a wrestling
legend we know what you can do in the
ring was there a part of you that was a
little nervous about starring in a movie
like what made you say yes i was just
intrigued i think more so uh
you know the way it was presented to me
and like i said the interactive part
that's what um
i think was the most intriguing to me
knowing that the the audience would be
able to make really uh
important decisions and how the the
movie turns out and what happens to the
new day at the end so
it was uh that really captivated you
know my interest and and to see like
well this could turn out you know this
could turn out so many different ways
and
um and then you start thinking about it
and well you then you start hoping like
well if they play it one way
and they choose this decision are they
going to come back and then they're
going to want to do it again and then
see what happens if they
so it was just a uh it was just a really
cool concept to me
let me tell you right now this reporter
right here was along for the ride i went
back i went back to see what other kind
of like end beans i could find and you
guys really did shoot a lot of alternate
you know directions and endings for a
movie it was wild it was fun how fun was
it speaking of to work with the guys of
the new day in this new way i never
i mean i i've worked a little bit in the
ring with them uh but not near i never
had a program or really spent a lot a
lot of time being creative with them
right and those guys it was well i think
what was really the coolest part of it
is their energy right they have such
this dynamic positive energy
and then you
you put that in contrast to
the undertaker which is obviously a dark
you know which is a dark force and you
you kind of like i was a little leery at
the beginning when i'm thinking you know
conceptually yeah i'm thinking
um is it going to be is is it going to
be too funny or will it be you know will
it take the undertaker too far out of
his out of his roots but um
it was just the opposite
energy played against mine so well they
were a nice balance to the undertaker's
darkness you know it was really fun to
watch
are you a fan of the horror genre do you
like scary movies um well are you
kidding me i mean
really you kind of have to right yeah i
was you know early on when i was
doing this character i mean that's
i mean that was my study i mean that's
what i studied i i could have told you
anything about jason voorhees or michael
myers freddy krueger or you know any of
those guys because i watched all that
stuff for and looking at you know the
way they handled themselves and little
nuances and and and so
yeah i mean i've always and i like just
as even as a kid i like being i like
scary stuff and it was it was just uh
you know it was destined to be
so it's the undertaker season right now
right it's time to get spooky
yeah this is the this is usually the
time of year i take off but uh
we're gonna take it off oh my gosh so
what 2020 is when you uh took a step
back from wrestling from wwe are we
calling it a retirement because i know
wwe is full of surprises something tells
me we have not seen the last of you
um
as it as this moment um yeah my days in
the ring
are are are done
and it's not because i don't want to be
in the ring i mean that is where i've
spent the most of my adult life my my
whole life really right uh more than
half of my life has been
spent in in the wrestling or sports
entertainment ring and uh
uh so in my mind
i still can see everything
and in my heart
you know i want to be out there but it's
just at a point where my body can't
deliver what what what my mind and my
heart see my body can't deliver that and
i just don't want to cheapen
uh
the legacy of that character and i'd
hate for people to
pay money to see me work and be
disappointed you got a young daughter to
chase around over there at home you know
you know what she's actually right now
back in the back watching it for the
first she just got yeah she just got
home from school so she's back there and
i hope y'all can't hear it but every
once in a while i can hear ooh ooh
oh my god so she's having fun watching
it it sounds like oh yeah yeah yeah
she's having a blast did she get to
watch a lot of your matches at all are
you you know in action she uh yeah she
saw quite a bit um
we
we kind of protected her those early
years didn't want her seeing daddy get
beat up too but but once she kind of
started figuring things out
um it was pretty hard to keep her away
and and of all my kids she's probably
the one that i need to keep the closest
eye on from swallowing in daddy's
footsteps because
she she can she knows the ins and outs
and she is uh she could probably tell
you more about today's product than i
can wow yeah she's really in tune with
what's going on yeah so are you prepared
to be a dad slash manager i mean or at
least a coach she has probably one of
the best coaches and sports
entertainment ever the undertaker i'll
tell you what i don't know i don't know
i mean if it's in her heart and that's
what she really truly wants to do one
day i'll do my best to coach her up and
obviously her mom will too
um
but yeah we'll see what happens we got
we have we have a long way to go before
i start worrying about that yeah until
then she can watch you on on netflix
yeah she seems to be having a good time
doing that so hopefully
that'll cover it i saw that margot
robbie recently revealed an interview
that she was a fan of the undertaker
growing up what does it mean to have a
fan like someone like margot
well i mean obviously it's extremely
flattering i mean obviously she's one of
the
um you know she's one of the hottest
actresses out there in terms of of what
she's putting out or movies and that
whole you know that whole series so
um it's always cool to see people from
different uh
genres that are that are fans because
you just sometimes you forget right that
you're also you're uh you're a form of
entertainment and
and so people are you know people from
different uh genres are are fans of
things too and um
i would have never i would have never
placed that one um
you know but uh i thought it was really
cool that uh that she had mentioned that
don't you see a glimpse of it now though
when you are able to see margot kick
butt as harley quinn in those suicide
squad movies like now i'm now i see that
yeah
right
totally oh totally yeah you can
definitely see it i mean she would be
she'd be an awesome character for for
wwe she'd hold her own quite well looks
like for sure well speaking of that you
know we've seen a few celebs um appear
on wwe most recently bad bunny over at
wrestlemania is there a celebrity or
someone famous that you think could take
on your contemporaries in the ring like
who would you want to see kind of show
up and pop up
you know what i did
bunny set the bar man he set the bar
super high i tell you what of all the
people that have crossed over and done
uh you know some cameos for us i mean he
killed it and he
i was i mean
you know he trained
i know he trained i mean obviously it
would be different you know doing the
full schedule right um
but what he did i thought it was utterly
amazing i was blown away uh by how good
he was while we wrap things up i have a
quick rapid-fire set of questions for
you about the undertaker about spooky
season my first thing is what is the
undertaker's favorite scary movie the
birds alfred hitchcock yeah
yeah old school stuff yeah yeah the
thing it was always with the scare which
you know it all got into
slash and gore and all that which i
think always kind of took away
eventually took away from the scariness
hitchcock he always loved it with the
theater of the mind like he left you to
think like what happened to in psycho
you know it's just like
i always thought that was definitely
your mind what you think in your mind is
far scarier than any special effect they
can do so it's kind of old school but uh
what else would you expect from the
undertaker that's right that's a good
one you weren't lying that you do love
the genre i love that um what's the
undertaker's favorite halloween candy
i'm not a sweet guy but uh let's go with
skittles
okay
taste the rainbow
taste the rainbow yes i say skittles
because it'll be all they'll be all over
skittles and candy corn will be all over
the house here shortly there you go what
scares the undertaker like does the
undertaker have a fear yeah
michelle mccool
yes
and finally help all those folks out
there what's the key to a good
undertaker halloween costume you gotta
have a classic coat and the classic hat
you know a lot of times i see them and
they got
people will get hats and coats that are
too small or
and then you just kind of go i mean look
you were i know where you were going
there but you didn't land
you didn't quite you didn't quite stick
the landing
got to have the hat you got to have the
coat and uh and if you got an eye roll
in you man then that's money
[Music]